all right welcome back to game on vegas
i don't think anybody knew how nice
allegion stadium would end up looking
it really is a crown jewel of all
stadiums no corners were cut no
amenities were left out and in fact
it is one of a kind there isn't another
stadium in the world
that can boast what contains inside that
thing with unique pieces of art
it's probably fair to say the stadium is
the biggest art gallery in the world
this is the biggest baddest stadium
that's ever been built behind the black
outer walls of this death star is
something far
far away from what you'd ever imagine
being hung in this two billion dollar
portentous palace
[Music]
there are over 400 original works of art
michael goddard is curator of what you
could call
the allegiance stadium museum of fine
art
see the two goals very very clear goals
we had tell the history of the raiders
and tell the history of las vegas and
bring the two of them
together so we had so much
rich las vegas has a lot of rich history
as does the raiders
70 of the city's best artists were
hand-picked from a pool of 250
to leave lasting impressions on these
walls the artists were given a task or a
subject or something like that
and then to see their interpretation uh
you know i'm like oh my gosh
definitely that was the right person to
do that we kind of chose the themes
and we you know chose which artists
would do what theme
and then we kind of let them you know
run with it a little bit you know they
they submitted their sketches you know
we got them
either approved or maybe a little change
here or there but
they really had a lot of creative
freedom to you know make this their own
interpretation and make it something
amazing you're going to see every style
whether it's an oil painting an acrylic
whether it's
my medium of marker whether it's
photography
it's brilliant stuff it's not just about
raiders football las vegas is displayed
proudly and prominently on these walls
if we tell the story of vegas if they're
here for the first time and they don't
know anything
they want to know everything and you
know literally they can walk down the
the history wall that we have all right
in my luck
i'm taking my chances with all the odds
of my favor
i'll let my money down if beauty is in
the eyes of the beholder there is
something for everyone
each painting has detailed inscriptions
that can be accessed by anybody viewing
the art
i love the fact that he's got the little
qr codes
so if people really like a piece they
can go and you know scan the qr code
learn about
the project of creating the original art
what medium it was done and
a little bit about the artist different
people might see different things but
there's a little qr code
and you say wow that's really neat i
really like that i wish i knew more
about
you could take your phone out scan the
qr code uh
out pups out pops their uh their bio
and uh the materials they used and what
the name of the painting is
and what inspired them to do this
particular thing
we kind of had to get all that
information too you know we wanted to
find out more about the artist
and you know why this piece meant
something to them let's just say you
like this painting you want to know who
drew it and why and what were the
thought processes well now you have that
chance
the autumn wind is a raider pillaging
just for fun
he'll knock you around and upside down
and laugh
when he's conquered and won there are 56
000 square feet of framing neil
portnoy's art of raider legends is 28 by
40 feet
when i first saw the first panel being
done and they said what do you think i
said well
what the hell is that and they went well
that's bo jackson's
eyebrow i mean it was four feet wide
crazy just crazy
not one fan has seen a touchdown behind
these walls or heard a single voice from
a concert
basketball or boxing those days are
coming but already hanging inside
is the dressing that completes this
palatial palace
we did a lot of studying for that you
know months to really know
everything about the raiders everything
about vegas so that you know whoever
comes in here that there's something for
everyone my hope is that everyone who
comes here obviously has a great time
takes away something and somehow they
can
connect and it's a be an unforgettable
experience you know
not only are they gonna enjoy when we
win that game that they're attending but
you know they'll get to see some other
stuff we're in a place
in its initial stage of history
that's pretty cool yes indeed he's
pretty cool hey you'd like to see more
of michael stuff you can check out his
instagram
at goddard's crazy
life all one word consider the rock star
of art world
great stuff on his side his daughter
maddie who you saw some of her pieces of
art on the walls her instagram
officially is goddard too also check out
neil portnoy's instagram
portnoy neil portnoy if you'd like to
see his stuff they are all so
talented right now you can take tours of
the facility but your first chance to go
inside and witness the beauty of the art
will be this summer if you're lucky
enough to have tickets to garth brooks
ufc 264
or grab tickets to the concacaf gold
medal soccer game
those three big events are scheduled to
be staged inside
the facility this summer